again your book is called them
enlightenment now Mao's in a writ very
very large on one hand you kind of have
a relaxed view of history because you're
saying things are getting better but
there is a real urgency about this book
what's at stake and how much time do we
have I think what is at stake is a
cynicism and a fatalism about
institutions that have strengthened
since the Enlightenment that pushed back
against the darker side of human nature
that are very much worth cherishing such
as liberal democracy such as
organizations of international
cooperation and there's pushback I don't
I don't want to say they're on the verge
of collapse but there I don't and
science and fact-checking journalism
basically institutions in dorms toward
truth and human wellbeing they're
threatened I don't think they're on the
verge of collapse I don't know if it's
if it's yet rises level of crisis but
they're certainly threatened and not
just by a forces of authoritarian
populism but by cynicism and opposition
also from certain sectors of academia
and intellectual life as well so I
believe that the these Lichtman values
need a defense for fear of sounding like
you know the miserable press that puts
you know negative headlines on the front
page
you know when does steven pinker gets so
alarmed that you actually start saying
you know this is really serious you
mount the barricades you know with your
trumpet and you say it's time to get you
know it's time to panic
well the I don't know if it'll be time
to panic but certainly the rise of Trump
and authoritarian populism are around
cause of deep concern anything that
elevates the threat of nuclear war such
as the standoff between the escalation
of rhetoric between North Korea and the
United States a year ago news about
climate if it doesn't if we don't have
policies that start to push back that
would certainly be cause for concern so
these are again it's the if if panic is
the response then read then that would
not serve any purpose but if it's but if
it's in but if
if the deterioration is incremental
right where do we and we kind of and we
don't even notice it going downhill when
is the right moment to jump in oh oh we
should we should always monitor
everything so if things go down
gradually we should be aware of it year
by year as we are in the case of climate
change worse that's not a catastrophe at
least not yet
but we can measure co2 emissions we can
measure climate we can measure sea level
and so we can see it happening well
before a catastrophe
you